The information below is valid for a 10
acre site being sized for a retention
basin. Consider the hyograph and
accompanying information.
Infiltration occurs for the first 30
minutes at an even rate of 0.03 in every
minute. Transpiration is also constant
at a rate of 0.01 in per hour.
Depression storage and surface storage
at the area in question includes 5,000
gall of available capacity.
If the depth of the retention basin on
site cannot exceed 10 ft in depth, what
is the required size of the retention
basin in square feet?
So over here we have our hyata graph. We
can see the yaxis is in inches per
minute and the x-axis is in 10-minute
increments of time.
Now, there's nothing in the problem
statement that would necessarily make
you think, "Oh, I should search for
these words." But there is a section in
the civil reference manual under section
6.5.8.1
titled surface water system hydraologic
budget.
Again, I don't know what you would
actually search for, but it might be
helpful just to know that this exists in
case you want to study it or review it.
so that you know where it is if you feel
inspired to find it during the exam.
But even without it, we can go through
the terms that the problem statement
gives us one at a time and find
our retention basin that way. So the
first thing we're going to do is find
our rainfall volume in cubic feet. And
while we're doing this, we're also going
to account for the infiltration at the
same time.
So we can see that infiltration occurs
for the first 30 minutes at an even rate
of 0.03
in every minute. So let's just go to our
hya graph and cross off 0.03 in of rain
for the first 30 minutes.
What that shows us is that the first
half of the hya graph won't actually
contribute any buildup to the rainfall.
But we can still sum the rain that
occurs during the second 30-inut period.
That's going to be 0.04
+ 0.02
+ 0.01
to give us a total of 0.07 in per
minute. Now if we multiply by 10
minutes, this will bring us to 0.7 in of
rain over the whole hour that are not
infiltrated.
From there we can unit convert to get
this into
cubic feet. So first we'll multiply by 1
ft over 12 in.
Then we'll multiply by the 10 acres on
the site.
Then we'll multiply by the conversion of
43,560
square ft per acre.
And we can
multiply these out and cross out our
overlapping units to get 25,410
cubic feet.
Next on the list is our transpiration.
We can see that this is just a constant
at a rate of 0.01 in per hour. So all we
have to do here is write down that value
of 0.01
in hour. But the height graph is 1 hour
to begin with. So it's really just
inches.
And perform the same unit conversions
that we did to get the rainfall volume
in cubic feet.
[Music]
And that's going to give us 363 cubic
feet.
Finally, we can account for the
depression storage and surface storage.
So, we can see that we have 5,000
gallons of available storage capacity on
site. That capacity will need to be
subtracted away from the amount of
rainfall volume as well since we will
need that much less detention basin. So,
5,000 g* 1 cubic foot over 7.48 gall.
And that'll give us 669 cubic feet.
Now that we've accounted for all of our
gains and losses at the site, all we
have to do is sum them up.
So our rainfall volume is going to be a
positive number
and all of these values are in cubic
feet.
Again,
transpiration is going to be a negative
value
and depression storage will also be a
negative value.
Solving this, we get a total of 24,378
cubic feet.
And now that we know the total rainfall
at the site that is
left over, we can design our detention
basin.
So if we know the depth can't get any
greater than 10 ft,
we can simply divide our total volume by
10 ft to find the square footage
required.
and that's going to come out to 2,437.8
square ft.
The closest answer to the left is the
first one at 2450.
So, this problem doesn't require the
reference manual, although it might be
helpful to you to know that the surface
water system hydraologic budget page
does exist just to review it. All you
have to do is grind through unit
conversions on this problem and just
make sure that you're accounting for
infiltration properly since it's greater
than the amount of rainfall during the
first half of the hyagraph.
And that's it.